[Musica]
energia quante volte sentiamo e usiamo
questa parola dai tanti significati
oggi vi voglio raccontare qualcosa che
non è del tutto noto di questo elemento
questa entità chiediamo tutti un po
troppo per scontata se ci pensate
finché non ci troviamo a non averla
siete mai trovati questa situazione
magari per qualche secondo magari per
qualche minuto
un tempo le mamme va a prenderla candela
che saltata la luce
mi date una mano proviamo a reagire un
attimo grande c'è già qualcuno che ha
capito questi erano tutti pagati in
prima fila
proviamo a fare abbastanza luce per
vedere se ci vediamo ancora un pochino
grandissimi vorrei fare una fotografia
splendido credo che riusciate già quasi
a vedermi grazie mille
riaccendiamo le luci in sala grazie
ragazzi un esempio banale lo so ma è
giusto per farvi capire come si possono
trovare soluzioni rapide ed efficaci
situazioni di crisi
lo sappiamo molto bene anche qui
soprattutto a brescia come abbiamo
reagito alla pandemia imprese
associazioni cittadini tutti che si sono
messi al servizio dell'emergenza
reinventando spesso il proprio lavoro
reinventando le proprie produzioni per
quanto riguarda le imprese o
semplicemente cercando di dare di dare
una mano ed è in questi periodi che c'è
una grande opportunità nella crisi come
ci insegnava questo signore col suo
splendido umorismo britannico winston
churchill
addirittura ci diceva non sprecate una
buona crisi perché quello che si può
portare appunto riflettere ripensare
ridisegnare riprogrammare
allora dicevamo che l'energia la diamo
per scontata ma c'è un miliardo di
persone come questi bimbi che non ha
questa fortuna che non ha accesso
nessuna forma di energia
i visi un po perplessi era perché
vedevano per la prima volta nella loro
vita qualcuno che veniva da un paese
diverso dal loro quindi sarà l'effetto
un po alien o gulliver viste le
dimensioni è però con alcuni di questi
siamo poi diventati amici lo vedete dal
sorriso di questo bimbo sorridente
nonostante stia portando un peso per lui
sovrumano perché questa è la condizione
in cui sostanzialmente vive gran parte
della popolazione in africa sub
sahariana senza e che in particolare a
pongo l'accento su questo la possibilità
di utilizzare l'energia elettrica magari
per pompare l'acqua dal sottosuolo per
bere o coltivare per coltivare i campi
ma a volte bastano piccole cose guardate
questo bambino attraverso una lampada
solare da 20 euro può cominciare a fare
i compiti per la prima volta nella nella
sua vita
noi abbiamo vissuto tre mesi in logan ce
l'abbiamo fatta con tutte le difficoltà
del caso le conosciamo tutti ma come
avremmo vissuto tre mesi in black out
probabilmente ci saremmo inventati
qualcosa in più di una lampada solare
per far andare i nostri pc i nostri con
i presenti smartphone eccetera e ma come
facciamo oggi a rivedere un po là
diciamola le priorità all'interno dei
nostri bisogni
questa questa è la piramide del signor
masslo
qualcuno di voi se la ricorderà e diceva
questo signore del secolo scorso uno
psicologo diceva ovviamente nella
gerarchia dei nostri bisogni ci sono
quelli fisiologici devo mangiare bere
dormire
ovviamente sicurezza amore e senso di
appartenenza fino ad arrivare
all'autostima
ecco oggi se lo chiedete non solo ai
giovanissimi
spero che signor ma sono così rivolti
nella tomba
ma alla base dei nostri bisogni
ci sono fondamentalmente queste due cose
i giovani si dicono anche prima di
mangiare
ecco cosa ci serve per avere wifi
batterie ovviamente tanta energia come
facciamo a produrre la quantità di
energia sufficiente in abbondanza a
costi competitivi e con un impatto
minimo sull'ambiente oggi che siamo 7,5
miliardi di persone siamo destinati a
diventare 10 entro il 2050 possiamo
consumare di meno
sì sicuramente c'è tanto da fare anche
sull'efficienza energetica
ma il punto che stiamo andando verso una
progressiva elettrificazione dei nostri
consumi pensate all'introduzione delle
auto elettriche le pompe di calore i
processi industriali si stanno
elettrificando sempre di più per fortuna
dire io perché a scapito appunto di
combustibili dei combustibili fossili
vi porto un secondo a farvi vedere che
cosa è successo
quindi nel nostro mondo bisogni che sono
sempre più crescenti e risorse che
sappiamo essere finite limitate almeno
alcune poi ce ne sono alcune che invece
così limitate non sono guardate cosa è
successo negli ultimi 200 anni dal dal
1800 fino ad arrivare ai giorni nostri
questa si chiama transizione energetica
in gergo sono le tappe fondamentali che
abbiamo vissuto
guardate come sono cresciuti i nostri
bisogni la nostra domanda di energia e
che cosa è successo dal legno sono
passati al carbone poi al petrolio poi
al gas
man mano che introduceva mo appunto
nuove nuove fonti e questo è stato
dettato da i bisogni appunto dalle
scoperte tecnologiche dalle economie di
scala perché l'economia che guida prima
di tutto questi processi cioè se una
fonte è più competitiva di un'altra
riuscirà a prendere il sopravvento ma
per arrivare a quella maturità
servono anche gli incentivi noi stiamo
vivendo oggi l'ultima tappa fondamentale
di questa transizione energetica perché
là sopra in alto lo vedete piccolino ci
sono le energie
rinnovabili che venivano considerate un
po fino a poco tempo fa li chiamavano
alternative erano come delle cenerentole
bistrattate si costano tanto
sono lì le mettiamo da qualche parte
eccetera pro oggi lo vediamo tutti che
hanno subito una uno sviluppo uno
sviluppo esponenziale perché perché oggi
non c'è un modo più economico di fare
energia elettrica se non con il sole e
col vento tanti ancora non mi credono
quando dico sono numeri che parlano
molto chiaro negli ultimi dieci anni il
costo di un pannello solare è andato
diminuendo dell 85 per cento
quindi stiamo vivendo una sorta di
diciamo primavera per queste ovviamente
su quella scala temporale e globale
siamo solo all'inizio
in tutto questo processo ma non ci sono
solo vantaggi economici ed ambientali
pensate no a non dover trasportare
quantità ingenti di fossili via terra e
via mare e pensate a cosa vuol dire per
gli stati che non hanno combustibili
fossili è una sorta di emancipazione
democratizzazione dell'energia perché
saranno sempre meno dipendenti dai
produttori di petrolio di gas come ci
ricorda un autorevole rivista qualche
settimana fa sta cambiando la
geopolitica dell'energia e direi
fortunatamente perché rende tutti un po
più autonomi indipendenti nel poter
utilizzare le fonti che abbiamo tutti in
particolare quella del sole e del vento
però esistono delle sfide come
dappertutto e qualcuno di voi conoscerà
o sarà avrà sentito parlare del termine
intermittenza questa è la prima sfida
l'energia del sole esiste quando il sole
splende si produce quando sole splende
quella del vento quando il vento soffia
una vecchia legge degli ingegneri del
mio settore dicevano ma energia non si
può immagazzinare
e quindi bisogna produrla nel momento in
cui ce n'è bisogno e questo comporta
ovviamente tutta una serie di
problematiche nella gestione delle fonti
e della della rete oggi quando nei paesi
anche dove ci sono tante rinnovabili
quando appunto bene scarsità perché non
soffia il vento 1 splende il sole si usa
soprattutto il gas
accendiamo e spieghiamo come il fornello
di casa le nostre centrali per sopperire
a queste mancanze per tenere accese le
luci e quindi sono fonti che oggi hanno
un ruolo anche o ancora molto importante
per la sicurezza energetica ma anche qui
qualcosa sta cambiando velocemente
vedete questi container che sono dietro
l'impianto l'impianto solare non sono
altro che delle grandi batterie al litio
come quelle che abbiamo nei nostri
cellulari che hanno la stessa funzione
hanno la funzione di accumulare energia
nel momento in cui c'è un'eccedenza di
produzione e reimmetterla in rete quando
ce n'è bisogno una rivoluzione nel mio
settore che sta finalmente prendendo
piede perché i costi delle batterie
stanno andando nella stessa linea che
abbiamo visto dei pannelli solari dieci
anni fa e quindi questo ci fa ben
sperare poi sfatiamo un altro mito fare
rinnovabili non vuol dire
automaticamente se sostenibile
pensate all'impatto di questo impianto
in messico 25 chilometri quadrati cinque
volte il centro di brescia meta di
manhattan
allora chiaramente ha un impatto qua
siamo in mezzo al deserto e quindi un
senso utilizzare le terre incolte per
dare tra l'altro energia un milione di
case messicane attraverso questo
impianto
però per portare per esempio due milioni
e rotti di pannelli solari in questo
posto ci sono volute centinaia di
tonnellate di pallet di legno su un
esempio è che sto facendo
prima il politico non si poneva il
problema nel senso che il legno andava
al macero punto poi qualcuno ha
cominciato a dire ma come potremo
utilizzarlo
o che uso ne potremmo fare si è scoperto
che nei villaggi intorno tra l'altro
potete immaginare in queste zone non c'è
grande ricchezza esistevano dei
falegnami esistevano degli artigiani
fatto altro che dare a loro il legno per
poter fare appunto costruire nuove
falegnamerie farci dei mobili che
vengono utilizzati a livello locale ma
che cominciano essere anche anche
esportati tra l'altro anche dal cantiere
stesso
ma questa non è beneficenza non è carità
questo è un vantaggio reciproco ed è
l'unico modo per far funzionare un
valore condiviso tra un'azienda una
popolazione che vive intorno cioè e
crearlo
questo valore condiviso in che modo
semplicemente in questo caso per
l'azienda costano di meno lo su costa di
meno lo smaltimento per i falegnami vuol
dire un canale di vendita in più e della
materia prima a costo zero quindi questa
è una oppure vi siete mai chiesti cosa
succede alla fine della vita di un
impianto eolico cosa si fa con il
materiale va rottame una parte può
essere riutilizzato riciclato un altra
parte una grossa parte no poi qualcuno
si è messo a pensare un po sempre
nell'ottica di ridisegnare riprogrammare
mettere conoscenze diverse
la multidisciplinarietà un po
l'intelligenza plurale o collettiva che
dir si voglia a ragionare su cosa farne
designer architetti ingegneri e sono
uscite fuori idee come queste che si
stanno realizzando questa è una sezione
di una pala eolica che diventa una
passerella quando appunto non serve più
per generare energia elettrica alla fine
della vita
questo non è altro che il vecchio detto
di nostri nonni no non si butta via
niente alla fine questa è quella che
oggigiorno si chiama economia circolare
che non è nient'altro che ridisegnare
riprogrammare i processi fin da quando
pensiamo ad un prodotto fin da quando
pensiamo ad un progetto ci dobbiamo
porre il problema di cosa ne faremo dopo
semplicemente e mettendo insieme appunto
conoscenze e competenze diverse nascono
delle idee e ce ne sono miriadi
veramente molto molto molto interessanti
quindi siamo sulla buona strada
ci stiamo spostando velocemente verso un
mondo così il problema non è se andremo
verso un mondo a 100 per cento di
energie pulite a zero emissioni
ma quando e se lo faremo rapidamente in
modo tale da evitare che i danni siano
irreparabili la retorica del salviamo il
pianeta
secondo me dovrebbe essere salviamo noi
stessi perché il pianeta vita che
qualche miliardo di anni
sicuramente ancora ci dicono gli
scienziati della nostra specie
no non è detto quindi cosa possiamo fare
però effettivamente effettivamente noi
tutto sembra legato ai governi alle
lobby alle grandi aziende che decidono
che decidono queste cose beh noi
possiamo fare qualcosa
tutti siamo d'accordo su uno stile di
vita sano
abbiamo recuperato vecchi mezzi di
trasporto come la cara vecchia bici per
usare meno la macchina
poi però magari compriamo una penna
online ce la facciamo portare con un
furgone diesel
questo solo per dire che ogni tanto i
nostri comportamenti sono un po
contraddittori e ci sono miriadi di siti
che ci parlano di come calcolare la
nostra impronta di co2
voi direte cosa mi metto lì ogni giorno
guardare anche no però sapere che
determinati comportamenti pesano molto
di più e che magari ci basterebbe per
noi un piccolissimo sforzo cambiare
un'abitudine piuttosto che un'altra già
ci fa pensare
quello che potrebbe essere un impatto
poi generale di tutto questo e quindi ok
queste sono le abitudine ma c'è
qualcos'altro che facciamo votiamo ogni
tre o quattro anni e quindi dovremo
stare attenti a quello che ci dicono i
politici
dovremo stare attenti che aria al
rispetto degli impegni anche su temi
come questo ma c'è una cosa molto più
importante noi ogni giorno
compriamo compriamo quantità gigantesche
di prodotti e cominciamo essere sempre
più consapevoli di quello che compriamo
pensate da un settore come il biologico
20 anni trenta anni fa quando parlava
nessuno oggi un mercato enorme perché
giornalisti attenti persone consumatori
che cominciavano a chiedersi che cosa
stiamo mangiando la qualità dei nostri
prodotti
eccetera hanno puntato i riflettori
sopra un settore sopra alcune forse
distorsioni che poteva avere e hanno
cominciato a chiedere qualcosa di
diverso
poi sono arrivati i governi a regolarlo
ma è avvenuto che i consumatori hanno
spinto non i governi
questo è un po quello che succede quello
che succede a per tutto oppure pensate a
chi ha deciso di fare della propria
giacca una campagna di questo tipo una
giacca sportiva fatta con materiali
riciclati
qualche anno fa negli stati uniti una
campagna fortissima dice non comprate
questa giacca
e nelle declinazioni successive a meno
che non ne abbiate veramente bisogno
quindi c'è chi comincia a utilizzare
molto bene la sostenibilità anche con
campagne molto efficaci da questo punto
per crearne un vantaggio ma l'energia
qui sembra che non possiamo farci molto
no cioè la nostra bolletta
questo lo paghiamo lo decidono se anche
quelle grandi aziende i governi no vi
siete mai chiesti
con chi energia sono fatti prodotti
alcune aziende cominciano a scriverlo
cominciano a dirlo pensate aziende come
questa
qui c'era una bella colonna sonora che
diceva the answer is blowing in the wind
questa azienda dice produce birra
l'avete capito
due anni fa durante il super bowl quindi
lo spazio pubblicitario più caro al
mondo comincia a dirci che la sua birra
fatta con l'energia del vento voi direte
greenwashing
no secondo me no perché se dietro c'è la
coerenza quindi lo fanno davvero non c'è
più spazio per chi predica bene e
razzola male perché ogni giorno viene
smascherato in pochissimo tempo
quindi non solo per le grandi aziende ma
poi se aiutiamo piccoli produttori che
magari mettono dei pannelli fotovoltaici
sopra le proprie serre o sopra le
proprie stalle
anche qui possiamo effettivamente dare
una di fare una differenza dal punto di
vista energetico durante il lock down
ci siamo accorti la natura si riprese ai
suoi spazi queste immagini che
ricordiamo tutti no ce n'erano una
valanga e abbiamo capito che forse
possiamo arrivare un modello diverso
anche attraverso quello che abbiamo
imparato nel reinventarci riprogramma le
riflettere abbiamo parlato con lo smart
working banalmente possiamo vivere in un
mondo che può essere un po più
decentralizzato un po più
decongestionato ma non solo dal lavoro
da casa ci sono state imprese che hanno
stanno digitalizzando progressivamente
la propria produzione per poter gestire
magari da remoto come è successo durante
durante il lock down con un gruppo di
amici qui a brescia abbiamo fondato
qualche anno fa una piccola azienda che
si occupa di queste stiamo vedendo un
grandissimo interesse
questo è sostanzialmente un altro
esempio di quello che si possa si possa
fare per ridisegnare riprogrammare il
nostro il nostro futuro
le città super intelligenti iper
tecnologiche dovrebbero secondo me a
diventare e dovremo ridisegnarle insieme
delle comunità quindi da smart city con
smart community di delle comunità che
possano mettere a fattor comune le
proprie competenze
la propria energia per cercare di
accendere forse quella luce quando tutto
un po buio come all'inizio o grigio e
cercare di creare un futuro che
fortunatamente secondo me non è più
quello di una volta
grazie
[Applauso]